mesi fa immaginate la scena
mi sono ritrovato davanti al notaio nel
suo studio con accanto a mio padre per
costituire una mia società
una volta entrato in alta fatta di
presentazione il taglio era curioso di
sapere qual era la mia professione io
per essere minimalista e per
sintetizzare al meglio il mio lavoro ho
usato il termine youtuber avessi mai
fatto
nell'istante che ho conosciuto questa
parola il avesse messo a ridere in
faccia e lo stesso a ruota
l'ha fatto anche mio padre e quindi poi
per fargli compagnia come saper vedere
anche ritrova è ci ridono tutti ce lo so
anch'io che previa ormai diciamo che
sono abbastanza abituato e questo perché
trattandosi di una realtà così recente e
ancora oggi potevo sviluppo
in pochi sanno quello che c'è dietro e
ice in pochi sanno quello che oggi
youtube è diventato infatti parlando poi
con il notaio posto andando un po quello
che era il business dietro questo lavoro
lui alla fine mi guarda mi fa cambiano
tono
va beh ma tu sei un imprenditore non 61
youtuber e lì quando mi ha detto questa
cosa
sono stato io quello che se ne sa ridere
quindi fa sono andata questa piattaforma
online che penso che la gente non ti
conosciamo che ha youtube.com lo slogan
inizialmente era broadcast yourself
ovvero trasmetti te stesso ed era così
ha inizio tutte le pressioni caricavano
video li caricavano i mod amatoriale
dopo sporadico senza una costanza e
senza nessuna aspettativa
io iniziai nel 2010 pubblichiamo un po
così a random come se fosse social
network ecco youtube era un po social
network quindi così come su facebook
magari caricabile foto o myspace le
canzoni su youtube mette di video in
modo puramente amatoriale e non esisteva
il concetto di fama o di soldi e questo
perché non siano neanche i like al tempo
c'erano le le stelline per valutare
diciamo e video
un po come oggi team advisor è quella
che però non c'era è la considerazione
per i numeri in parte anche la
consapevolezza
io nel corso degli anni quando ero
passato dal fare una media di 1000
visualizzazioni a video a farne magari
lo so 50 60 mila ero consapevole siti
magari dietro quei numeri ci fossero
delle persone sparse per l'italia o per
il mondo però non avevo capito quante
effettivamente fossero 50 o 60 mila
persone non avevo capito che le stesse
persone riempiono uno stadio di serie a
adesso ci arrivati per primi
sono passati brand che infatti hanno
subito percepito il potenziale di questa
piattaforma
il potenziale di quello che poi nel
corso degli anni sarebbe diventata
infatti brand da subito ha iniziato ad
acquistare degli spazi pubblicitari
tramite google su questo sito da mettere
appunto accanto e contenuti il sexy spot
che siamo stati abituati a vedere in
televisione
quelli che per intenderci partono quando
apriamo un video su youtube
quelli che dopo 5 secondi scappiamo è
questo qua è stato un po il concetto
dell'introduzione della monetizzazione
su youtube
concetto che dava quindi la possibilità
alle persone di avere un rientro in
quello che facevano
infatti grazie a questa cosa in base a
quante visualizzazioni facile di liber
rientro in termini economico e quindi
grazie questa possibilità le persone di
youtuber iniziato a reinvestire quei
soldi e missive magari anche altri per
fare altri video per implementare la
qualità e per magari imparare moltissimi
altri skill e questo viene cosa ha
comportato ha comportato che c'è stato
un momento molto importante della
qualità su youtube dei contenuti anche
io
passa dal fare video con la workman
computer a farli con delle reflex le
idee che inizialmente erano improvvisati
lì per lì sul momento oppure idee che
erano amatoriali appunto diventarono
sempre più complesse sempre più
strutturate e questo anche per
l'aspettativa che le persone poi avevano
dietro questi video nel senso le persone
su youtube possono commentare sotto i
video c'è la parte di interazione quindi
nel corso degli anni le persone
aumentano sempre di più la sicilia della
scritta dive è in mano a mano in questa
aumenta va in mano a mano che poi
aumentato anche il tuo pubblico
aumentavano anche nelle sue abilità che
avevi nel fare video
questo ha portato nel complesso a una
maturazione generale della piattaforma
maturazione che poi ha fatto sì che i
brand fossero sempre più interessati a
legarsi direttamente contenuti perché
magari contenuti iniziarono a
trasmettere anche dei valori iniziare a
trasmettere messaggi a condividere
appunto delle filosofie alle quali
magari prendono associarsi e quindi
brand lì iniziarono direttamente a voler
investire sul contenuto sulla persona
che ne sarà introdotto così il concetto
un po di testimonial oppure il concetto
dei prodotti platespin di branded
content questo indicativamente nel 2015
in quell'anno io facevo il quinto
superiore e non sapevo in realtà ancora
cosa fare dopo
dopo quell'anno non sapevo cosa fare
finta la scuola perché perché da una
parte avevo se questa grandissima
passione che era fare video e
condividerli passione per la quale ero
consapevole assieme tutta una categoria
che grazie a questa evoluzione dei brand
poteva se fatto in modo costante e con
un rigore diventare un vero e proprio
lavoro
da una parte c'era questa mia
considerazione e consapevolezza di
quello che tu sia piantando mentre
dall'altra c'erano i miei genitori che
speravano ci hanno lasciato fino
all'ultimo che gli appuntamenti sia la
scelta più più comune inter messi un
percorso universitario
meno rischioso la scelta fu posta perché
non essendoci delle casey sta
divorziando cinquini delle regole da
seguire
il rischio è molto alto però nonostante
l'ansia di questa cosa nonostante
l'ansia anche di vedere un po i miei
genitori decise comunque di provarci
quindi mi sono trasferito a milano è
iniziato a far sì che quello che posso
vedere dal suo lavoro per farlo io non
sapevo appunto si fa certe avevo preso
era quella giusta ma sapevo quelle che
sono un po da regole del lavoro o meno
che per fare un lavoro devi essere oltre
che appassionato perché la passione è
importantissima però non basta solo
quella deve anche essere molto preparato
e di essere stakanovista mi devi dare il
massimo di me stesso in conto di fare e
ci ho provato dal punto di vista
formativo quando la grande perché nel
primo anno
imparai e implementati tantissime cose
tantissime nuove competenze il mio
lavoro ho conosciuto anche un sacco di
persone cliente quindi ho creato anche
un polo elector che dall altro punto di
vista invece quello lavorativo
ci ho messo un po a entrare nella
mentalità giusta perché nonostante io
avessi già fatto dei lavoretti come
magari il magazziniere cameriere era
diverso quando si dipendente ai degli
orari e delle regole da seguire ai delle
responsabilità limitate e quindi
psicologicamente parlando è più semplice
per lo meno per me è stato molto
semplice quando se il capo di te stesso
per altra causa
forse per l'età forse perché l'opera
trasferito però insomma è difficile
perché non sai quello che devi fare è
quindi il modo che deve applicare è
quello di importi delle regole imposte
degli orari delle schede dei programmi
giornalieri e settimanali importi degli
obiettivi ed essere oggettivo delle
scelte che fai
osare provare rischiare però essere
sempre consapevole di quello che stai
facendo insomma perché se sbagli iceberg
e capita di sbagliare è che avete un
sacco di volte e anzi sbagliando il
famoso detto sbagliando s'impara e
bellissimo io tutti gli sbagli che ho
fatto ad oggi non solo
sì che migliorasse che crescesse e
quando può tentare di essere i miei
genitori che hanno sempre lasciato la
libertà di imparare sbagliando per me
colori essere un emissione insegnamento
poi lasciare adesso con un'idea
cerchiamo di loro idee più di fronte
ogni volta che sentiamo qualche nuovo
termine qualche nuova professione
cerchiamo più che altro di approcciarlo
secondo beneficio del dubbio perché
viviamo mario matt per cui tutte le cose
viaggiano a velocità impressionante in
queste le cose si evolvono in tempi
strettissimi
vediamo il mondo in cui nessuno conosce
le regole per questo forse perché non ci
sono delle regole in questo mondo grazie
a tutti